start a podcast even if you don't put it
out publicly Do It For Fun you'll learn
so much about yourself especially if
you're someone who wants to improve your
social skills
start a podcast and take it seriously
right so have a nice setup get a camera
if you don't have a camera use your
phone make sure it's video not just
audio
and sit down and just once a week for
one hour record an episode it could be
about whatever you want
but say you take that step you'll record
your episode and then you'll review it
you'll be like okay well how was it how
did I do
now what's going to happen
is you're gonna probably start looking
up other podcasts and you're not going
to see them the way you had previously
seen them it's not going to be this fun
entertaining thing you're going to be
filtering it through your experience
doing your own and you're going to pick
up on subtleties you had previously not
even picked up on right